hey youtubers its charlie happy holidays
hopefully you guys have had a chance to
see Star Wars The Force awakens this is
going to be like a top 10 question
video just some of the biggest questions
from the movie so careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet we will be
talking about things that happen in the
movie I feel like we can all agree that
there are a thousand questions that we
have coming out of the movie really more
questions than answers because there's
so much that the movie doesn't explain
so I could probably do like 10 of these
videos but I just I wanted to pick the
biggest ones that I saw all you guys
commenting on on my non-spoilery review
so here we go and actually the the
giveaway is continuing I'm giving away
two imax gift certificates a lot of you
guys requested that I wait till like
after the weekend to name the winner I'm
totally fine doing that so they give
away we'll just stay open all weekend
first big question this is kind of in
chronological order kind of not but
starting with Max von Sydow who is lor
San Tekka
that's the character he was playing he
had the missing part of the map to find
Luke Skywalker kylo Ren seemed like he'd
known him for a long time so I'm
guessing he worked with Luke Skywalker
at the Jedi Academy and that's how he
knew where to find Luke Skywalker or he
was associated with the Academy somehow
the speed with which he was taken down
by kylo Ren makes me think he wasn't a
Jedi but he could have been question
number two what caused Finn's character
to break his conditioning so in order to
answer this question we have to explain
what's going on with the stormtroopers
the first order takes them from their
homes as children then brainwashes them as they become stormtroopers so they
just they feed them whatever information
they want they tell them Luke
Skywalker's evil the New Republic is
evil the resistance is evil so they're
basically like a bunch of zombies
walking around they even make the dig
about the clones like maybe we should be
using a clone army maybe they big bettor
general Hux is like no no my
conditioning is perfect what causes
Finn's character to break that
conditioning it seems like he's not
force sensitive it seemed like you know
what they were telling us in the movie
is that he's not going to become a Jedi
so my thought is is that there's no
logical explanation he broke his
conditioning because JJ Abrams needed
him to because the story needed him to
the story makes a couple leaps and logic
that just do not make sense the
characters are amazing there are some
holes in the story so I think Ben
breaking his conditioning is just like a
gaping hole in the story question number
three this is a big one how powerful is
kylo Ren if he's not as powerful as
Darth Vader but he can stop blaster
bolts and hold them in midair without
really giving it a second thought well
he just walks around even really trained
Jedi have to work really hard to hold
things in the air so written have to be
pretty powerful to be that quick you
know to catch the charged plasmas it's
coming out of the barrel and then just
hold it there like it's no big deal
while he walks around talking to people
but then side tangent how powerful is
array if she's able to defeat him in
single combat if she's never touched a
lightsaber before and never tried to use
her powers my thought is another gaping
hole in the story like the theme things
that JJ Abrams never intended to explain
like he just wants to see kylo Ren doing
cool things like he wants that cool
scene but it doesn't necessarily need to
make sense so I think it would only
cause more problems if they try to
quantify kylo ren's power I think he's
going to be as powerful as he needs to
be to have good fights with Daisy
Ridley's character the way they're
positioning them I just think that Ren
and Rey are going to be equally powerful I
think that's kind of the idea question
number five if kylo Ren's real name is
Ben solo and he's Han and Leia's son
what is his connection to Rey if he kind
of knew about her at the beginning of
the movie when he found out about the
bb-8 droid this is going to be one of those
things that people debate for a long
time like who has raised character who
she related to because she's clearly
related to some of the characters and if
you think back when the officer was
telling kylo Ren the Droid got away with
the FN stormtrooper there was a girl
with them the minute he said girl he was
like wait what did you say there was a
girl with them and he you know Yanks him
across that to me is just like one in a
series of clues that Rey is his sister
and JJ Abrams Brian II think like a lot
of people are complaining that the film
is a remake of a new hope just think
about the Luke and Leia relationship
across the first trilogy and think about
what would have happened if Luke had
gone to the dark side and Leia had had
to redeem him that that's why I think
that Ray is kylo Ren's sister but that
doesn't answer the question of why Han
Solo like if Rey is Han Solo and Leia's
daughter why didn't either one of them
acknowledge it verbally like why didn't
say oh my god you're our daughter
welcome back that could be Mindwipe it
could be another gaping hole in the
story like because they don't want to
reveal it up front I know a lot of
people want to believe that she might be
Luke's daughter but I feel like the look
that she got from Luke at the end of the
film wasn't the look you would get from
a father seeing his daughter for the
first time and I like many many years
the look on his face was more worried at
the sight of Anakin Skywalker's
lightsaber and what that meant I'm not a
geneticist or anything like that but
there is like a probability aspect to
having twins like if you're a twin
you're much more likely to have twins
when you have babies we can debate till
the end of time but on to the next
question
why is kylo Ren so conflicted if he's
supposed to be evil he's been training
with Supreme Leader Snoke why does he
keep beating his head against Darth
Vader's melted helmet they've kind of
answered some of the questions through a
lot of the press junkets and stuff you
know them talking about the character
kylo Ren is just a character who hasn't
completely gone to the dark side like
he's he's still kind of teetering back
and forth Snoke is trying to turn him
for his own purposes but there's still
the pull of the light side the chance of
redemption which like I said is where I
feel like Rey's character is going to
end up like she's going to try and
redeem him like Luke redeemed Vader
there was still a little bit of good in
Vader but the difference between kylo
Ren and Vader is that Vader had been
working with the Emperor for a lot
longer than kylo Ren had and as we see
in the movie kylo Ren knows that his
parents are still alive which is why he
you know he murders Han Solo because he feels like getting rid of them will get
rid of the pull of the light side kylo
Ren right now to me is kind of like Luke
during Empire Strikes Back where he
leaves his training with Yoda early to
face Vader is like kylo Ren isn't fully
trained yet that's why Snoke at the end
of the movie is like general Hux bring
kylo Ren to me it's time to complete his
training on the number eight though
what's going to happen to Finn now that Rey
is with Luke Skywalker with r2d2 and
Chewbacca Finn kind of got put in
carbonite so to speak so I mean he's
definitely coming back he's still alive
but my thought is just based on his
character traits he reads like the new
Han Solo the person who's really brash
just rushes in to help people without
completely thinking things through winds
up having to be saved more often than he
saves people but has a really good heart
side tangent to Poe Dameron though his
character to me is kind of like Luke
Skywalker the pilot League just the
pilot aspects of Luke Skywalker best
pilot in the galaxy always happy to help
his friends just doesn't have the
force-sensitive arc that Luke had in the
original trilogy so Finn and Poe Dameron
are probably just going to be running
side missions trying to take down the
first order because finn has unique
knowledge of the first orders workings
question number nine
another really big one what happened to
kylo Ren in the past what happened to
Ben solo that Snoke was able to turn him
to the dark side and convinced him to
kill the other Jedi at the academy
we actually get a picture of the Knights
of Ren because Rey has like this flash
into the force she has this force vision
of the Knights standing around Ren as it
looks like she's seeing into the past
when he killed a bunch of the other Jedi
so it seems like what they're saying is
as Snoke found Ben taught him about his
heritage like he learned about Anakin
Skywalker and Darth Vader and was
seduced into thinking that he could make
things better using the dark side and
that the Jedi were somehow evil in
trying to stop him from doing that
because whatever Snoke told him he would
have had to convince him that the Jedi
were evil that'd be the only reason to
have to kill the other Jedi really it's
one of those stories that I expect that
they'll tell a little bit more in
episode 8 in episode 9 they'll also
expand on with the written material like
the the novels in question number 10 of
course all about Supreme Leader Snoke
who the hell is he WTF in is he really
big like we saw him in the hologram or
his he tiny like Yoda and Maz Kanata
neither one of those things where I feel
like they're going to tell the story of
where he came from in a novel they're
not they're not going to completely spell
it out in any of the movies but I do
think that the hologram was kind of a
misdirect I don't think he's ginormous
like that hologram made him seem but I'm
just going to cross my fingers and I'm
going to hope that he's going to be really
really small would that be I mean
they'll be kind of funny if they made
the hologram really big it'd be too
on-the-nose so I'm going to lay odds on him
being smaller like Yoda and Maz Kanata
just just because that seems to be the
thing in the Star Wars universe where
it's like the smaller you are the more
frail you are the more powerful you are
but hopefully the answer is at least a
few the biggest questions about the
movie there's still going to be tons
more and I'm probably going to do an Easter egg video in a couple days after I see
the movie a couple more times so
everybody have an awesome time going to
see the movie again hopefully you've
seen it at least once by now I'm
definitely going to see it at least two or
three times this weekend mostly for
Easter Egg purposes but it is a really
fun movie even though there are a couple
plot holes
it totally does not ruin the movie just
in case you guys haven't seen it yet you
can click here for my episode 7 review
video and you can click here for my top
10 funny deadpool moments thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
and i'll see you guys!